NARRATOR: "The
tyranny of distance"
is a phrase that keeps coming
back to Elliott Ross when
he thinks about this picture.
The scene feels so small
that at first blush,
talking about distance
and isolation seems weird.
That is until you learn
that the man in the picture
intends to make this cave his
home and that outside the cave,
is the whole of the
Australian Outback.
(MUSIC PLAYING]
This cave is actually
part of a small mining
town called Coober Pedy,
which is a name with a pretty
great history.
ELLIOT ROSS: Coober Pedy,
in the indigenous tongue,
means "white man's hole".
NARRATOR: That's
Elliot, the photographer
who led us through this place.
Anyway, Coober Pedy got that
name because 100 years ago,
European miners found opal here.
And true to form,
white men have been
digging holes and excavating
the precious stone ever since.
Though nowadays, miners from
all over the world live here.
For Elliot, who
traveled to Coober Pedy
to learn about the community,
it was a shocking place
to see for the first time.
ELLIOT ROSS: For
miles and miles,
it's just plain red clay with
lumps and little hills of dirt
where people dug holes
looking for opal.
And abandoned cars.
And I was like, oh my gosh.
What is this place?
This is incredible.
NARRATOR: What the place
is is a study in extremes.
This part of the
Australian Outback
is scorchingly hot, bone
dry, and more than 300 miles
from any kind of civilization.
And it's prone to dust
storms that sound like this.
[DUST STORM]
A place this extreme
certainly feels tyrannical.
But according to Elliot, it
also creates a certain frontier
spirit.
Take for example opal mining,
which the residents have
managed to keep in
their own scrappy hands
and away from big
mining corporations.
ELLIOT ROSS: People have made
these incredible machines.
Every single part is homemade.
It's really a special thing.
NARRATOR: Or consider the
subject of that first photo.
Most of the residents of Coober
Pedy live in underground homes
to avoid the sun and the heat.
And the man in this photo,
who Elliot called Eddie,
was looking to build a
new home for himself.
Elliot met him and
toured what was
so far a hole in the ground.
But it was Eddie's
hole on the ground,
and like any good frontiersman,
he saw it as much more.
ELLIOT ROSS: I was
like, hey, Eddie,
can you sit in that chair?
He looked at me like-- I
think we need a picture of you
as the benevolent dictator
of this underground lair.
NARRATOR: Elliot has visited a
lot of distant, isolated places
in his travels.
And after being welcomed in
and shown all of Coober Pedy,
he's got a theory
about places like this,
and it's a theory that's
really gotten under his skin.
ELLIOT ROSS: You need to
have some sort of hospitality
to survive and for your
neighbors to survive.
So there's this
codependence that
builds and grows and nurtures
in this sort of environment
that I think is beautiful.
And a lot of people kept
repeating this one thing
like, you know, if you
stay more than 10 days,
you never leave--
[INAUDIBLE], 10 days.
10 days, you fall under our
curse, and you'll never leave.
I ended up staying, I think, two
and a half weeks there, it was.
I didn't stay, but a lot
of me wanted to stay.
NARRATOR: If you
loved this episode
and you want even more "Seeker",
checkout "Seeker Stories"
on Vessel, where you
can get all our videos
three days earlier than
anywhere else on the internet.
Click the link in
the description
for your free 30-day trial.
If you're looking for
more stories like this,
check out this video
about what it's
like to take a
vacation to the most
isolated country in the world.
MATT PAISH: You did
get the impression
that they had just
been created purely
for tourists to go to on a bus.
There were no other
people around there.
NARRATOR: And as always,
don't forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]